would you rather give up The Hungover
breakfast sandwich or the drunk Pizza
I'm gonna go I'd rather give up the
drunk pizza because I gotta say I'm not
really a drunk pizza guy he doesn't
really do it for me when I'm drunk also
when I'm drunk I'll be trying to eat
healthier recently I could eat anything
drunk like there's some times I'll make
a grilled chicken and have it waiting
for me drunk I could live with that but
I'm not even The Hungover breakfast
sandwich the only thing I wouldn't give
up is The Hungover Diet Coke McDonald's
drive-through that's better to eat than
the breakfast sandwich I would never
give that up for anything that's the
only reason I drink is to get the
McDonald's Diet Coke in the morning like
you know when you wake up from drinking
your mouth is so dry and then just drive
right to McDonald's get a small Diet
Coke and just that first sip it's like
it's it's like you're losing your
virginity for the first time it's crazy